the fed is is losing its independence to
the executive branch and that is a
problem and joe biden wants that problem
right i mean
he wants more control his solution for
joe biden to a lack of ability is more
control
meanwhile joe biden can't even control
his own party right so the the internal
democratic war continues a pace
so yesterday joe biden joe biden is now
seeing that the american public hate his
gods and are not interested in his party
controlling congress his new answer is
just a plain old conspiracy theory if we
lose it's because they rigged the
elections now again it is incredible to
me and we have spent
a couple of years here talking about how
donald trump perverted american
elections and he's undermining faith in
american elections meanwhile the
president of the united states is
literally going around
to places like georgia and saying that
if votes take place under current rules
it will have been rigged
that any election procedure that takes
place in republican state can
effectively be questioned and thrown out
because the procedures are rigged
what he is saying is no different than
anything trump said
except he has even less evidence of
voter suppression than trump had of
election fraud and yet the media are
just on like this is what joe biden
tweeted yesterday he tweeted this
jim crow 2.0 is about two insidious
things voter suppression
and election subversion
it's about making it harder to vote who
gets to count to vote and whether your
vote counts at all
we have to pass the freedom to vote act
and john lewis voting rights and rounds
win
okay so um jim crow 2.0 so he's
immediately saying
that every election security law in
america is about preventing black people
promoting it's jim crow 2.0
he says it's about voter suppression
name the voter who has been suppressed
mr president a voter one just one who's
been suppressed who's been prevented
from voting in the united states
name a human one it shouldn't be hard
you're saying it's happening millions
and millions and millions of times over
in republican states right now name them
name one you can't because it's a lie
elections he's saying that
not only are you preventing people from
voting you are then subverting elections
by literally changing the counts right
he's saying who gets to count the vote
is the real question
you're changing he's accusing
republicans of not only rigging who gets
to vote but then rigging how the votes
are actually counted
that is a full-fledged conspiracy theory
it's madness
okay so he's failed on every front and
so his new solution is to suggest that
votes are being stolen in the united
states and that everyone who opposes him
is a vicious racist in favor of jim crow
meanwhile he's trying out jen saki to
explain that you know when he says that
you love segregation and that you're
with bull connor that's not divisive
that's just the truth
the president delivered a powerful
speech about uh the protection of
people's fundamental rights in this in
this country which is their right to
vote the right to to vote for anyone
they choose whether it is him or someone
else it was not a partisan speech it was
intended to lay out for the public
exactly what's at stake and lay out for
elected officials what's at stake
and he stands by everything he said in
that speech
yeah i'm sure he does i'm sure he does
because he's got nothing else when in
doubt if you're a democrat call
everybody a racist and the person who
probably is best placed to call
everybody a racist is an 80 year old
white man who used to hang out with
george wallace in the senate probably
that guy that one
good caller by the way he's destroying
his own party this idiot is so bad at
this he's destroying his own party right
now
he has chuck schumer up on the hill
proposing proposing a vote on this
voting rights bill this this nonsense
garbage federalization of elections bill
and he doesn't even have full democratic
support for it
joe manchin and kristin cinema don't
even support it
get like like this is crazy he's so out
of control and so incompetent at this
that he's not content with destroying
his own
executive branch leadership he's
destroying his own senate majority in
real time at the best of chuck schumer
who's simply trying to avoid a primary
from like aoc
it's unbelievable so in synopsis is this
guy a good president this guy is the
worst single president in american
history after one year
man i cannot wait to see what the next
few years bring my goodness
the battle for the culture is heating up
we here at the daily wire are making
some big moves so be sure to like
subscribe ring that bell because you're
not going to want to miss a single
moment